welcome everyone to new coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant today i will talk about one
of the most common mistakes that young
leaders young professionals people
working in consulting or also in
industry are doing it's a mistake that
many people confuse with having been the
victim of corporate politics but no if
this happens to you it's not due to
politics but it's on you it's a mistake
that you made i trust it is going to be
juicy and extremely relevant for every
young professional out there so in this
fictive scenario there was a team lead
to work on an important new initiative
over the last weeks now there's this
meeting where this person is presenting
the progress and also the way forward on
his or her initiatives to the senior
leaders of the organization but now what
happens these senior leaders actually
criticize the approach they do not agree
with the proposed action plans they do
not agree with what is being presented
to them at this point in time and indeed
due to this the whole meeting is
derailed and of course also the
reputation of the person presenting this
will suffer the standing will take a hit
so does this sound familiar think about
it what went wrong could that person
have done something to prevent this and
i won't really to literally stop the
video now just read through this and
reflect on that what is your opinion on
this could this person have done
something differently to shape this
meeting in a way to lead to a better
outcome
let's get into it what could this person
have done and to better understand that
i first want to look into the typical
process that a typical team lead in such
a situation will likely go through and
indeed this process consists of three
steps so first that person will conduct
analysis and derive results often
together with the team to then get to
something that can be presented and
indeed this is then the second step
prepare a presentation prepare slides
prepare a document and then of course in
the end there's the presentation itself
where the pages are being presented and
are being discussed in the meeting so
let's go here step by step step number
one what happened here well of course
often information has been gathered by
colleagues other sources maybe some
expert interviews that this person will
have conducted you do this together with
the team and then you derive the results
together with your colleagues on the
topics at hand second step when you
structure then all the analyses into
some type of presentation document of
course hopefully you apply the good
slight writing principles the
communication techniques top-down
communication
principle that we talk about so
frequently here on this channel if all
of this says nothing to you i will link
a playlist above here where you will
read about more of these topics watch
videos on exactly this last but not
least there's a presentation of course
often the team lead will deliver this
presentation him or herself in front of
the senior leadership of the
organization and now once again i want
you to pause the video and think about
that thinking about this approach will
this likely be successful will this
likely lead to a good result
and my humble opinion in my experience
is no this will not work right because
what is the problem if you do this this
process often leads to negative outcomes
as also shared in the initial example
why because the team did not manage to
align the results with all the key
stakeholders of the organization
alignment one of the most important
topics in every big corporate in
consulting for sure it is a topic so
common so important in consulting that
it is literally a meme here my friends
at consulting humor prepared this little
quote
just had a meeting to a line on how we
would align with the client during our
weekly alignment meeting right alignment
alignment alignment alignment you will
have lots of meetings every week just to
align content by the way consulting
humor really a great channel for humor
like this i will link the associates
below in the video description check it
out great content i can promise you but
why is it so important to line content
align documents before meetings let's go
over some typical problems that arise if
you do not do this if alignment is
missing well first of all colleagues
will likely not have any buy-in in the
solution that you present as they were
not involved in the solution process
next point valid concerns were not heard
and reflected in the solution maybe
there were really some important things
that the senior leaders of your
organization were aware of that you just
couldn't be aware of but of course now
you don't know because you didn't
involve them you didn't align your
solutions your contents with them next
there's the natural tendency to defend
the status quo and think about the
reasons why proposed change is bad if
you just propose something new something
that will change the status quo and
someone just hears it for the first time
likely the very first reaction will be
ah nah probably not but probably we
don't need to do that next point very
much related to that no one likes to be
surprised especially not in front of the
colleagues if you walk into a meeting
then suddenly you hear something see
something that is very surprising to you
that you did not expect at all ah that's
likely not great and especially if then
your other senior colleagues are sitting
next to you because this also just makes
you look uninformed unaware of what is
going on in your organization especially
if this was your direct superior and
that person didn't even know what you
were thinking about what you were
working on that just bad because this
also makes that person look bad next
point it is also just very generally
considered unprofessional you will be
expected that you will have a line key
results with all the key stakeholders
even if maybe the people did not
directly task you to do that that's just
an expectation towards the role of a
team lead in such an organization and as
i said in the beginning many people
confuse these types of reactions with
politics oh that person didn't like me
that person had something against me
that person didn't want me to succeed
right and pretty much blame it on the
culture of the organization this is not
what's going on you are hiding yourself
from the truth it was your
responsibility it is your responsibility
to make sure that these types of
alignment errors don't happen but let's
not discuss what this team need could
have done to properly align the results
the contents of the work with the senior
leaders with the stakeholders how could
the person have improved the outcome of
this important meeting and by the way
before we do it if you took any value
out of this video at all so far please
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm of course also subscribe turn
on the notification bell to stay up to
date with all my content this is very
very much appreciated but let's now look
at it step by step for all the three
steps you initially outlined and start
with the first one to conduct analyses
and derive results and here the mistake
that many people do is that they see
their colleagues also their clients just
as some data sources you just walk
around the organization just request
information from people then for you to
do the analysis and to do the work well
of course you do need all of this
information this is not to be confused
with properly co-creating solutions with
the relevant colleagues so if you're
leading such an initiative very clearly
think about what the people are that you
want the buy-in from think about some
appropriate workshop formats or other
good ways to directly involve them also
in the process to make sure that they
feel like they have been part of the
solution that they feel like it was
maybe even their idea what you proposed
in the end this often goes a long way
next never never never walk into meeting
with your senior leaders and letting
them see the document the first time but
what i mean is that you properly take
the time to in the one or two weeks
before this is very important meeting
you meet with all these people one on
one and you guide them through the
document if it's not the final document
because it's not ready yet then at least
the rough outline the key results that
you want to share and you ask them for
their feedback you ask them for their
guidance and this is of course
especially important also in consulting
and potentially especially challenging
and consulting because they are not only
you need to align the documents with
your clients but you also need to align
all the key documents with your internal
leadership and this can be quite
challenging because often you end up
going in circuits right so you create a
document align it with a client then you
take the document show it to your
partner and actually your partner
disagrees the partner i think no this is
not what you can do so you turn around
the document then you go back with this
document to the client and then the
client says no i disagree right and then
this can go really in circuit so that's
often quite a pain especially as a
project lead to moderate all this and
then last but not least for this
presentation in front of the senior
leaders very carefully think about
whether you are really the best person
to present it and of course i understand
that maybe you think ah it would be
great for myself to get this visibility
get the spotlight present in front of
all these senior leaders but sometimes
it might make more sense for potentially
a person more senior than you to present
it this is actually even more important
than in professional services where you
often usually try that the clients are
actually presenting the results of your
project of your work it's always so much
more convincing to for instance the
board of management of a large company
to see that the results are not being
presented by external consultants but
internally by the team leads of their
own organization because this and also
to the board shows that this is not just
the crazy consulting idea which
afterwards people just throw in the bin
but this is something that their own
organization really dies into but now
let me know about your experiences any
crazy anecdotes you can share on the
lining actually not aligning things in
the proper way let me know in the
comments also if you have any other tips
on these types of topics of course as
always big big thanks to all the members
of the channel thanks for your support
very much appreciate it my name is
heineke release weekly videos here on
the channel see you again next week
until then all the best to you and bye